[Music]
the movie adaptation of perhaps the
world's most popular game is gaining a
new cast member and Mickey Mouse is
getting gory the MCU and DCU aren't
enough for you no worries here comes the
Nintendo Cinematic Universe while Marvel
is losing another actor learn about this
and much more in this week's Koch
news scary and beautiful news HP
lovecraft's short story the call of
cthulu is considered one of the most
influential and best known of all time
now it seems that a suitable director
for the project has finally been found
in James Juan published in 1928 the
classic the call of cthulu revolves
around Francis thirston who comes across
mysterious sculptures and documents in
the estate of his deceased uncle that
tell of deaths blood rituals and other
atrocities gradually he becomes involved
in a cult that wants to bring a cosmic
monster called kabulu to life although
the story has enjoyed great great
popularity over the decades only a
45-minute silent film made in 2005 has
been released to date however this is
now set to change Juan is regarded as a
master of his craft and has breathed new
life into the horror genre with movies
such as Insidious and The Conjuring we
can therefore assume that the adaptation
will be just as Eerie and Visually
stunning as the
original casting news for the Minecraft
movie Jack Black joins the adaptation of
the popular video game and Accord
according to the initial rumors will
play the role of Steve the movie
adaptation of the million selling game
Minecraft is set to be one of the major
highlights of the next few years and
will'll have players of all ages eagerly
looking forward to it Warner Brothers
announced a Minecraft movie back in
2014 however numerous postponements and
recastings behind the scenes prevented
the project from going ahead in the
meantime though the movie is regaining
momentum and has already managed to
secure a celebrity name in the form of
Aquaman star Jason Mamoa not not too
much information is known about the plot
yet but according to some leagues it
will be about the Journey of a girl who
travels to the world of blocks with a
group of adventurers to save it from the
ender dragon as deadline has now
announced Jack Black will also be
appearing in the movie alongside Mamoa
according to initial rumors he could
possibly be playing the role of Steve
although fake news about Pedro Pascal
being cast as Steve kept doing the
rounds in recent months this time
everything seems to be set in stone as
black has already confirmed his
involvement VI Instagram considered a
passionate gamer himself Jack Black will
appear in a number of future adaptations
in addition to the Minecraft movie these
include the second part of the Super
Mario Brothers movie and Eli Roth's
Borderlands movie adaptation in which
black will voice the iconic robot clap
trap distributor Warner Brothers plans
to release the Minecraft movie in
theaters on April 4th 2025 let's hope
that everything continues to run
smoothly until then should you want more
information about the movie feel free to
check out our movie preview
are we witnessing the dawn of a Nintendo
Cinematic Universe at least if
illumination has its way which according
to initial reports is planning a
Cinematic Universe together with
Nintendo that will include a Super Smash
Brothers movie and several spin-offs
it's hard to imagine the current movie
industry without cinematic universes
whether it's the MCU the DCU or the
monsterverse around Godzilla and Kong
thanks to the success of the Super Mario
Brothers movie which grossed over $1.36
billion world worldwide the animation
studio illumination now also seems to
have taken a fancy to it according to
Hollywood Insider Daniel rpk the studio
has submitted a pitch to Nintendo
describing the creation of a shared
Cinematic Universe based on initial
information this will include a number
of spin-offs and an epic Super Smash
Brothers movie in Super Smash Brothers
which first came out in 1999 as a game
for the Nintendo 64 you can compete
against Nintendo's most popular
characters these include Super Mario
Mega Man Pikachu and samaron from
Metroid for example Marvel's Avengers
which brought together existing
superheroes from the MCU is to be used
as a model the pl spin-offs could
explore which characters have the most
potential for a movie of this kind Jeff
Fowler meanwhile could possibly be
considered for directing after all fer
has repeatedly expressed an interest in
producing Super Smash BRS and brings
with his Sonic movie adaptations the
needed experience to the table
nevertheless this initial information
should be taken with a grain of S as
there is still no official confirmation
from Nintendo nor illumination until
then we can look forward to the recently
announced Zelda live action movie and
the not yet officially announced sequel
Super Mario Brothers
2 Amazon has apparently leaked the
release date for the fourth season of
the boys until now information regarding
a release was rather limited but the
leak has now revealed a very specific
date June 13th
2024 the date has been circulating on
Reddit and other platforms if this
information proves to be true the boys
could resume 2 years after the last
season however it's not completely out
of the question that June 13th is just a
temporary placeholder Amazon May of
course react to the leak and postpone
the series to a different date based on
initial information the fourth season
will be set after the events of the
final episode of the spin-off series gen
V which was released last year the
events from the spin-off will also play
a role in the story of the main series
however the Creator stated that it is
not essential to have seen gen B in
order to continue enjoying the
boys news from Harley and Arthur
director Todd Phillips published two new
stills from the eagerly awaited sequel
on his Instagram channel in one image we
see Arthur imprisoned in Arkham Asylum
indicated by the hatch on his cell door
in the second image he appears to be
outside the prison at his side is Dr
Harlen quinzel Alias Harley Quinn played
by Lady Gaga her look reveals that she
finds the Joker visibly fascinating in
terms of content Joker FY Ado is set to
continue the story of the first part
Arthur will receive support from Harley
Quinn after he ends up in a psychiatric
War presumably as in the comics she will
initially work as a psychiatrist and
later fall in love with her patient
Arthur and become infected by his
Madness the movie has been conceived as
a musical and is therefore likely to
differ significantly from the style of
his predecessor until the planned Cinema
release those responsible still have a
little time left to put the finishing
touches to the film Joker 2 Folia do
starring with Keen Phoenix and Lady Gaga
is slated for release in theaters on
October 4th
2024 sheer horror 96 years after the
release of the Disney classic Steamboat
Willie the very first version of Mickey
Mouse is now a public domain the result
two new horror movies are to be made
starring the icon we were already
introduced to a bloody version of a
cuddly bear and his friends last year
with Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey
although the low budget film fell short
of expectations in most respects a
number of horror producers seem to have
taken a liking to the idea of taking on
formerly innocent Disney characters now
the first ever version of Mickey Mouse
who made his debut in the short film
Steamboat Willie released in 1928 is
also being targeted Steven lamort who
was already directed a parody of the
Grinch called the mean one will be
responsible for an as yet Untitled movie
adaptation in an interview with variety
lamort Ed himself as a big fan and
disclosed his plans for the character
saying that Steamboat Willie has brought
joy to Generations but beneath that
cheerful exterior lies a potential for
Pure unhinged Terror besides the movie
with lamort another version entitled
Mickey's mous trap is to be released in
March with a trailer that has been
released just in time for the new year
Disney however does not seem at all
satisfied with these recent events and
has announced it will continue
protecting the rights to the modern
versions of its characters this is
somewhat understandable as planned movie
adaptations such as Bambi the Reckoning
Peter Pan's Neverland Nightmare and the
sequel Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey 2
which is scheduled for release on
February 14th are likely to be anything
but
familyfriendly the New Year is off to
another bad start for Marvel it has now
been announced that The Walking Dead
star Steven Yun is leaving the
production of thunderbolts the movie
directed by Jake shrier already had to
deal with some difficulties last year
due to the former writers and actor
strike there were several delays the
movie was originally due to be released
in theaters this winter now it is set to
Premiere July 25th
2025 however things are not particularly
well apart from that either as The
Hollywood Reporter announced that The
Walking Dead star Steven Yun is quitting
the production of the action-packed
movie the actor explained that the
reason for this was scheduling conflicts
with other Productions Yun was actually
supposed to take on the role of Robert
Reynolds AKA Sentry who received his
superhuman abilities through a super
soldier serum he is considered one of
the most profound characters in the
entire Marvel universe and has already
taken on characters such as the Hulk
Carnage and Thor in an interview with
variety Yun lamented his departure from
the project at the same time he
emphasized that he had always wanted to
make a Marvel film of course this could
mean that we might get to see him in
another MCU project after all it remains
to be seen whether the role of century
will be played by another actor or if it
will be dropped from Thunderbolts
altogether we'll probably only get a
final answer to this question once the
movie is released in
theaters were these still not enough
movie updates for you well then we have
two exciting videos to share with you on
our channel one is a series preview of
the upcoming House of the Dragon season
2 and the other is the previously
mentioned movie preview of Minecraft we
think you might really enjoy these
videos also how many more cinematic
universes do you think we'll get let us
know your opinion in the comments and be
sure to give this video a thumbs up
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next
time
[Music]